Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P here is a caller who's upset
that I didn't end up reviewing the Mypillow
pillows and that it was Pat who did.
Speaker 6: David, it's Alan from Jersey. I'm
watching the bonus show. Yeah, you know, the pony
show where all you want to do is make money, but
everybody else that makes money is bad. Oh, the.
Speaker 2: Bonus show where you want to
make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is.
Speaker 1: Bad. Exactly.
Speaker 6: And you promised us that you would
review the pillows. Yes. Now, Mike Pillow broke
his promise because he never sent you the pillows
until you finally shamed them into sending you the
pillow. Correct. Fine. He broke his promise,
but eventually he did send you the pillows.
But you broke your promise for you promised to
review the pillows. Not. Not send your silly
boy pad four of you the pillows. Right? No. You
promised to review the pillows and. Fine. Okay,
Pat, you know you're too busy. You know, Mr. Big
Shot gave a tagline to Media Review Pillows. So
you said you had to review them. I didn't even
review them. Have said he tried to pose for 20
years and gave up. No, that's not a review.
Speaker 1: Okay, listen, guys, this isn't a
pillow show, so they didn't send me the pillows.
Then they offered to because they heard I was
telling people pillow didn't send me the pillows.
I told Pat, quite frankly, I've got enough pillows
and I've got a lot on my plate. Pat tried the
pillows. He couldn't even fall asleep. So, yes,
after 20 minutes, he bailed and switched back to
his normal pillows. That's the review we were able
to do. Sir, I apologize with tears in my eyes. If
you want to see Pat's review of my pillow pillows,
it's on the bonus show earlier this week. We've
got a great bonus show for you today. We'll talk
about the border wall. We'll talk about Elon
Musk censoring speech on Twitter. Could it be?
We will talk about a call to end Georgia runoff
elections and so much more. Sign up. Join Pascal.